[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is youtuber Viner
rapper vlogger the talented and
tenacious destorm power destorm he's a
2011 American Music Awards winner with
over 1.6 million subscribers on YouTube
and he is the number 21 topped ranked
Viner with 4.6 million followers
I mean we're happy to call DeStorm a
friend of ours we've collaborated on
multiple occasions we discussed the
first time we met which I have forgotten
but he brings up in our conversation and
all the time ago I was glad I was glad
that he brought that up because I
certainly remembered that meeting once
once he once he made you remember it you
remembered it yes his YouTube fame
really exploded when he started
performing rap songs based off of
challenges from his fans and a schedule
that he also shares with us his
catchphrase was another challenge it was
a challenge from his fans and then he
would just have less than a week to turn
it into a catchy rap song just like this
one involving solving a Rubik's Cube you
got a problem yo I'll solve it watch me
take this color cube and help you
resolve it wanna solve your rubik's cube
first you gotta pray I'm only kidding
let me show you the way
you get the top which is relatively easy
it all starts out with a simple TC i
lying it's Eve with the colors on the
side what's the fine DeStorm also writes
and performs original songs for his
YouTube channel his most recent one of
those is victory dance
[Music]
[Music]
in your mind I got meals upon mine
but as of late day storms been getting
amazing traction on vine racking up
millions of loops six seconds at a time
actually up to six and a half seconds I
learned that today I got to say I'm a
little ignorant about that with vines
like robbery gone wrong we're a day
storm and fellow Viner very popular
rider king batch approached a man to rob
him only realize that when he turns
around he's a priest
what did you say much so the more that
you watch this thing it kind of sucked
you in the funnier it gets I mean what
you can't do it justice just by hearing
the audio and there's just a fascinating
science to the world of vining that
DeStorm has not only experienced but
helped dictate what is most successful
on vine I just I love the fact that this
is that he's able to talk about it in
such a detail way and that we could find
vine to define it and define it by his
action so I mean it was really cool to
talk about that we talked to him about a
lot of things his bizarre kneecap injury
a detailed account of his amazing
backstory I mean we're talking the type
of stuff that should be in a movie
tomorrow and I don't you know if DeStorm
wants to get into more acting I guess he
could play himself I'm hard rocker clam
that would also be literate for another
reason
you could play him that would be weird
let's not get into caste Alisa my point
is that his story is it should be in a
movie
yes but it's here on an air biscuit and
you're gonna enjoy it and we also talked
about its frustrations with YouTube and
all the new opportunities that vine is
affording him so keep listening for that
90% link that is the percent of your
life that you're in your underwear oh
okay I mean you're you know you have you
been keeping records because that's
creepy
I think I'm 98 maybe 99 maybe even more
than 99 now we're under we're pretty
much all the time except when I'm
bathing the reason I'm talking about
this that's it you just because
everybody knows the feeling of putting
on putting on old saggy underwear but
you need to know the feeling of great
fitting underwear that's 2 times 2
time's softer than cotton you need to
know about me undies dot-com alright you
heard us talk about me undies before
they are the most comfortable underwear
you will ever wear it's insane how good
they make you feel and not just where
they are they make me feel good
emotionally every where they fit
perfectly they don't ride up and they
literally pull moisture away from my
skin making me feel cool and you look
cool but I mean I don't see you in them
but you look like you Yuki so you're
keeping record of what percentage of my
life is that underwear and how cool I
look at my no this is no no not you just
people who wear these look cool I have a
big mirror in my bedroom I'll see myself
in them oh and Rhett has shared that he
has gone full me on D you have no other
underwear I'm on the verge of that
because I have a good set of them and
I'm noticing a phenomenon when I go to
my underwear drawer now there's a
telltale test and that's not a that's
not a fun or I guess it was and which
ones I reach for and I always reach for
the me undies and then when they're gone
I got to go to these other pair and I'm
now I'm just not happy or school they're
lacking the other ones are lacking and
so the ladies won't be left out these
are not just underwear for men they're
stars for men and women you can check
them out on the website and also we'll
make it easy for you you can go to me
undies dot-com / rhett and Link get 20%
off your first order with free shipping
and you can save you more if you buy a
pack of them they guarantee you're gonna
be happy or your first pair is free once
you fill me undies on your body you'll
never go back and remember to get that
20% off go to me undies comm / rhett and
Link now enjoy our air biscuit with
DeStorm power
so how long have you been without eating
how starving are you right now
I'm starving I got over like 7 a.m. Oh
to start the day because you know with
you don't eat breakfast
no just just dinner well but I haven't
had them because I had an interview at
Fox none of this sounds right so a star
it fills for me no I know you feel good
you know after you deaf - you eat that
man but what about what about the what
about that theory about eating a bunch
of little meals during the day it's a
great theories I'm a personal trainer I
believe in that there you're doing the
complete opposite though well yeah it's
just so I can just get like really nice
and sexy real quick okay I want to hear
can you tell us the kneecap injury story
the kneecap injury I was with Amir
Johnson from the Toronto Raptors because
this was oh really this is because this
was two years this is when we shot
Christmas sweats yeah I was messed up
yeah it had happened you were just in
recovery then and so it's been over two
years one two over three years ago
no is yet so it must have been much
Merry Christmas face oh it's Christmas
face but I've been obsessed with this
story so I want to hear it in its
entirety i what happened I had a show
that I was actually filming for YouTube
called make me hot where I actually
write a song for an athlete and in
return they have to make me hide me a
respectable sport so episode one was
what's the girl who won crazy shrugs who
won the Olympics member she flipped and
landed on one leg and got it for the ROI
yeah the girls so she was episode 1 she
was showing me some stuff on the balance
beam and in return I had to make her a
hot song we did the song episode 1 was
great episode 2 was Amir Johnson from
the Toronto Raptors okay and my job was
to make him a hot song in the studio and
in return we opposed to do a little
one-on-one basketball we did the
one-on-one basketball then we decided we
want to have a dunk contest so we're up
there with just dunking basketballs we
just going crazy with it no no how tall
you I'm six one almost six six six one
six and a half two six one and you can
dunk a basketball
I mean I'm six foot and I couldn't I
can't touch the net Oh
I could grab the room from the
free-throw line I'm black oh go back
there okay let's start with that you're
black okay dunk contest mm-hmm um so
this wasn't part of the actual show we
were just showing off and then we were
outside and I slipped on some gravel and
a hyper-extended my me and I guess all
those years because I was a professional
triple jumper in my time also everyone
who knows i was Olympic Development
triple jumper so I had a lot of balance
so I went up on that right leg and when
I went up on that right leg you just
heard this loud ass pop was like and
that was my knee in midair it's on you
two I'm pretty sure you saw the video
cuz we were shooting it for there for
the YouTube video I know I haven't seen
it I'll go watch the video stop talking
no but I went down BAM landed on my back
and I was kind of in shock so I was
looking for my kneecap so I'm on the
ground where the hell is my kneecap
could you what do you mean you looked
and the kneecap was not there it wasn't
there therefore you started looking on
the ground yes
that's what you're supposed to do
because it wasn't a knee when a part of
your body is not amazing explain so I
would change falls out of your pocket
when wait I must be on the ground
exactly when something falls apart from
you about you like you were looking for
a lost contact
you're like crawling around if you were
in the military that makes me something
if you're in the military and a part of
your body gets shot off in war you're
gonna look for your arm or your leg no
yes
okay so I was looking for my kneecap it
wasn't where it was supposed to be I
grew up with kneecaps for 32 years and I
wanted to know where my kneecap was and
it wasn't and it wasn't there and then
what so I'm looking at a mere Johnson
stands over me and he's like there's
your kneecap it was in my thigh okay so
wearing the thigh well my patella tendon
which is one of the biggest tendons in
your body popped this tendon holds your
kneecap onto your tibia bone which is
the bottom you know like bone in front
of your calf muscle so for the people at
home and it wasn't there so it rolled up
like a fruit roll-up like my quad my
rolled up like a fruit roll-up and my
kneecap was still as you know take to
that yeah
so I didn't see it because I didn't look
as high as my thigh and I was just
looking on the ground how many inches up
your thigh are we talking oh there's
about four or five inches up my back
it's just like a kneecap bulge it had to
be about six anyone when you found it
we're like I found my kneecap that's
about nine inches at one time so I'm
looking for my kneecap and he told me
where it was he gave me guidance we call
the images do you start like working it
back down like a tube of toothpaste or
what smart that's what I did yeah I did
that you see that every woman's supposed
to do that exactly that's what I'm
trying to say cuz we're human did you
google this first no it's funny that you
did the exact motion that I did what my
kneecap was locked that's exactly what I
did I would have I would have fainted
that's the motion I would have done
while you're in shock because you don't
feel anything when you pop something so
big was it did it hurt immediately or
just really because it's so big it's
like it when someone gets stabbed 27
times they just call the cops they don't
feel the staff there's so much it's so
much pain that overwhelms your brain so
that's what happened then when I got in
the ambulance I cried like a [ __ ] but
you know before that I was good but
before you got a name the ambulance you
push it back down all the way but it was
instead it wouldn't stay it rolled back
up because there's no table where it's
like a yo-yo
like a window shade exactly so they
sutured it back together and I took it I
had to take nine months on I had to do
nine months on the corner on the crutch
and yeah and that's when when you showed
up for I guess it was Christmas face
faces you had did you have a cat you
didn't have a cast on it then so the
cast was off yeah so I did nine months
in and I was just doing live I had a
very weak leg the thing is like I got
small you showed us to be atrophied to
nothing right atrophy I you know I you
don't use that limp so it's about the
size of my arm I can show you a picture
where my actual right leg was the size
of my arm because it's just bones see I
had no muscles so it's funny how fast
you lose muscle I'm gonna eat this
granola bar as we speak because so fast
this one meal right here this is part so
you eat throughout the day and call that
one big meal
it's not really one melody I'm doing I'm
doing you get to eat when the Sun Goes
Down okay I got you I get it
the sun's down it is hey guys the sun's
down all right this is this is risky
cuz you're doing most of the talking so
you're right you have to swallow them no
I'll just hold it in my cheek bone like
a chipmunk everybody I think we've had
eating before on this show you know I've
done my fair share of eating the first
time y'all here eating all this show
holiday boy so we gotta talk vine I know
having talked to you over the years you
know when it comes to vomit it comes a
YouTube when it comes to any type of
social media you're a student of the
medium your brain like from the first
time I ever met you it's like your brain
is going 90 miles an hour in just laying
claim to take a remote whatever
yeah whatever the whatever the digital
space has to offer
mm-hmm so I want to be schooled on vine
you know I'm
we don't do vine why we've talked to
some Viners but I mean you know there's
only so much margin videos are too long
yeah they're pretty long yeah it just
takes too much time is difficult man I
find vine actually sometimes more
difficult than YouTube because you have
six seconds to make millions of laughs
it's difficult to do that you know so um
if your punch is not a lot of times when
we're creating a vine we get a team of
people together sometimes eight to ten
people we sit there when we come over
ideas and things like that and you have
to make it perfect so sometimes I've
iron could take hours to do just to get
that six seconds so good that everybody
liking on this it's funny because it's
such there's such a limiting factor such
a limiting factor what was your first
reaction when hearing about vine five to
six seconds like your first reaction
first thing you thought well vine wasn't
initially used for the skits that we did
we brought this kids to buy um because
it really was just used he was doing
like a little quick spurts you know at
first and then I saw some people doing
like quick stories and things then when
we started doing like the slapstick you
know quick skits it was like wow that's
this is something but but why what made
you decide to do anything and it's I
know it was cause of who you are nor was
there
something specific you have somebody
that you knew that was already doing it
no no um actually my boy bat started
doing it King bat started doing it a few
days before me and me and him kind of
like started to challenge each other on
it like oh now I got a thousand
followers and I think I started with
3000 followers by default because my
YouTube was big and he says well catch
me and I didn't want him to catch me
did you did you start were you like okay
we're gonna do this we're gonna do it in
this way like let's let's do sketches
yeah because we didn't know what we did
we started doing like just funny stuff
then then sketches just came about we
started we started doing like tricks cuz
back in the day you couldn't do effects
and things yeah cuz so when you were
actually using the app like you were
using the constraints of the app I'm
literally pointing and holding down
quite shoot yeah but we would trick the
camp we were trying to trick the
audience and do things that we would try
that everyday we try to do something
impossible with like an example so um
there were times where you would show up
in one area but and then stop violent
and show up again and try to make it
flawless so you like try to make a
flawless seamless cut you like putting
your iPhone or phone on a tripod like
how are you doing no we were we were
just shoot straight off the head so we
had like we had like what we'll call
shooters like some of the best vine
shooters in the world it's only when we
just practice the craft of shooting vine
so we practice like and then we had
different different pans that we've hit
like the whip pan then we hit like the
fish pan and we started to make up our
own types of shooting pans so actually
so we a whip pan was something where you
would like act like you slap somebody
and they would turn into someone else so
when's the book coming up so I mean you
know you can't really do anything well
cause you can allow you to actually
upload now so you can just you know and
like these days you could use iMovie
you're editing some editing the video
yeah I use iMovie it's Final Cut is for
me or whatever there was an intermediary
period there when you had a hack to do
that before they allowed YouTube oh you
had to hack your way in you had to in
order to upload a pre edited video right
it was called handbrake so you had to
handbrake the video it was like three or
five or six steps you had to go through
but you can also do six point nine which
people like but that's not a lot more to
get a half a second but I have a second
when you got six seconds is a whole
world different that's a whole joke tell
us about you get an extra hold on you
get an extra half second when you was
uploading back
was able to do 6.9 so a lot of our vines
was 6.9 so it made it clear you could
make the joke more clear you didn't have
to do it in the restrain of 6.5 but now
now it's stuck at 6.5 they won't allow
you to anymore huh
explain the genius of the loop you know
I mean when you when you first hear
about vine is an outsider the first
thing is 5 to 6 seconds that's that's
nothing that's crazy that this this
could never be an art form we would you
know we didn't we never saw that coming
meaning me and then okay and it loops it
operated the loop made it phenomenal I
knew that it would be the next level
because the first time you watch is like
cool second level you chuckling and
third by time you see it five times not
only is it can a jingle be stuck in your
head but you're laughing out loud to
something that you didn't see was funny
or you miss things and you see again the
loop just made it ingenious especially
business-y so we we knew that I knew I
knew that it would just be the next
thing and I knew that's where Instagram
it messed up they tried to come back and
come back with video I laughed at and I
said you don't have the loop you messed
up and they still don't have they don't
have a look you know and and if I made
it so that the loop was seamless so the
loop comes back around and hits you in
the face every time so what you have to
do is you have to put your punch right
on that loop and when you do that you're
gonna make people laugh yeah that's when
you've got like the face or I mean oh
there's always something in each one of
your vines that when there's multiple
things but it's just like oh look at the
expression that right so we're hitting
with the expression or you know if you
okay you like we were just watching the
one where you're moving the guy's
scooter and then it comes up from behind
the fence and then you're like what is
this you got a helmet like you cut you
off in the middle of you has to be cut
off it'll cut you off in the middle of
the sentence and it was it's genius
it's great you know the slab has you got
to come up on a slab has to cut off in
the middle of a conversation because
that's what we will laugh at if you
finished a joke it's not a joke anymore
so the joke is the cut off how'd you
discover what people liked you know
trial and error I know within the first
three minutes whether or not I delete a
vine
whether or not you delete a file well
there's heaters and as the leaders you
know you know you got a heater because
you're doing your numbers your numbers
have to be looping you have to be doing
a certain amount of numbers and a
certain amount of likes or revine within
a certain amount of time
now you know it's a delete so off the
top even if you got team revine which is
basically yours crew who refines your
vines to help it blow up and make the
top of the popular page you know whether
it's a heat or delete it like so much
time I know and I I've been doing long
enough to know in three minutes
sometimes I wait till seven minutes and
what's the what's the percentage of the
leaders because you're trying to do you
I do about a day right no it depends
well as so much competition now but if
you if you're still in the top ten of
the comedy channel then I'll keep it up
and I don't have to do one until the I
could I could take a day off but if I'm
not in top ten then I know I fall down
into like the top 20 percentile then I
made the top 20 vine vines on the comedy
pages I know I got to do one the next
day and so what is the but then you but
but then the question of how many of
them are you deleting what's the
percentage they're like no it could be
one one out of ten two out of ten
sometimes really yeah I do about 80% I
mean it's certainly powerful in post
when you go back through them that's
like everything hits and there's not
like God and I have to have all heaters
on you or your channel so you know MERS
can continue to grow cuz when someone
new goes to your account you want them
to see either after heed them like oh my
god these guys the funniest guy in the
world and again all of these principles
you guys invented / discovery we made
them up and who is the who is the crew
that yours that you're talking about my
man crawling a batch yes it's about ten
people it's myself King Pat clarity
Melvin Greg Alfonso and watch the bow he
there's max Jerry and Dan you know some
of some of the you know like rudy
mancuso maybe even Logan and his brother
you know but the main page Kennedy
League amv even my assistant she's
getting into it it's really hard to find
funny girl sometimes work with Britney
but the main crew is usually the hub of
like 10 guys is like what's good well
you know whoever's in my group chat I
couldn't tell you why just looking at my
group chat because we have like no one
going a group chat that goes on every
day with us like homies and and then we
take the vines we throw them in the
group chat and if everybody doesn't
really approve you know we pretty much
you know
put it up so like you know I think I
named everybody that's just became yeah
but that's just to critique each other
you're not you're not pulling together
finances to write I mean is it it's more
please homies Devi's bonds like I'll
throw it in a group chat and it's kind
of like you know if they don't like ten
people just like it back yeah now I
definitely get the impression that there
are more successful black Viners and
there are successful black YouTube
comedians oh yeah and do you guys is
that what are the reasons for that and
do you think that you guys kind of
forming this crew is it's been
instrumental in that well you know you
had at one point kinda like YouTube you
had the la miners you had to Detroit
Viners yet the New York miners you hit
the Miami finals Danny all cupped and
everybody's in LA now because I'm so big
we you know our comedy troupe is just
like you know we would like to make the
LA - you know I'm I think it does play
the point that we do work with each
other and continue to help each other
the audience grow I'm like you know do
you doing YouTube but is it a black
thing you wouldn't understand kind of
situation no that's different than
YouTube or what it's nothing about the
it's cuz that the type of jokes you
could tell a vine you can't really tell
on YouTube because like you could tell
racial jokes and they're edgy or jokes
on your vine and on YouTube the comics
is different like if I tell the same
joke on YouTube I did something where I
slap a white person and then they slap a
black person back people on YouTube like
oh my god this is rishis gonna take this
down on vine is just like oh my god
that's so funny it's just the way we let
the audience's he vine like we say
there's so many times on vine they just
laugh now you said on YouTube they're
gonna definitely pull it you know I'm
saying vine is just one edgy and they
allow you to get away with a lot more
stuff on vine because it's like the Wild
West
so a lot of the jokes that we tell them
vine I can't do on YouTube my audience
on YouTube is just way more picky than
they are on vine they just crybabies
more so I know vine is just like okay
this is funny let's go you know it's
right type of you said table comedy I
mean is it is it like a different
audience do you have a wider audience on
YouTube and a blacker audience on vine
you don't even tell no you I don't I
don't think it's a difference I don't
think it's a different audience I think
it's different people I think it's
different people altogether I didn't I
never pushed my my vine for my YouTube
until I hit
you know almost 2 million followers on
vine I never even pushed it so like
there's a lot of people on vine I don't
even know I do music so if I go my god
you rap I'm like what I've been doing
this forever you know so right I never
wanted to mesh audiences like that I
always wanted to get a new audience
every time I even when I go to like
snapchat or Facebook I I built in
totally new audience where all the
fabulous looking women come from on your
in your vines oh well you know vine is
70 percent females so you always gonna
find five and everyone wants to do about
it the thing about they don't realize
how long it takes but they say it's just
six seconds of my time
that's why we work with everybody you
know that's why we didn't contact anyone
from Bieber to Floyd Mayweather to
whoever we work with and all we already
work with they contacted us because they
don't mind though in six seconds but
it's like YouTube like all the cameras I
gotta go here is just something I think
is all in the mentality of how people
think about it you know so people don't
mind lending you six seconds when it
comes to the late the beautiful women
aren't friends a lot of my friends
well I'm always gonna have beautiful
girls in my vines because we know that's
what sells beautiful girls sell and oh
and you get hit by every beautiful girl
in the world wants to eat you up once
you got those numbers alright so we're
going let's go back into business direct
yeah let's talk because I do want to
know I've heard yeah I've heard of
people throw around okay well yeah these
these vine brand deals are just going
going wild like brand deals are crazy
over there's no partner program no with
you tubing you slap ads around and over
and Google takes care all that and you
just get your cut and you know yeah but
with vine it's the Wild West like I said
companies hit you up independent Indies
hit you up you you know they sometimes
they just PayPal you a lot of money and
then you just do a six-second vine for
them there's times there's someone
you're proud of I did someone who beats
that that I still kept up because I just
like the numbers that I did on it you
know I didn't want four beats and what
was the creative like how did you put
was it the headphone where was the head
on the commercial thing you know they
did on the main commercial with um you
know the camera goes around the
headphones mine was on music changes to
time so I did something from the 80s in
2000 and 2015
I really have phones the whole time and
you want your your starts as a little
wardrobe a little no the module stays
the same but it starts as a mini me post
to be about I guess I'm like nine or ten
or
like five then it goes to like Sun who's
supposed to be me again he's 14 then it
goes to me you know grown man and it's
like the song's changed so goes from
like I think I'm Michael Jackson's song
to like maybe bye bye bye to the young
thug well you can't even understand you
use these unlicensed clips well that's
because it's the Wild West you can use
whatever you want online and what
doesn't cure there's no the agency
person or the brand person that you
always have you to it there's no ads or
whatever so they don't care you use
whatever you want to get any music you
want people love when you use their
music on vibe we want one of our main
jobs online is to break music I get
caught you know contacted from almost
every label out from Universal Capitol
we broke so many songs last year that
you probably wouldn't even know from
wiggle to my hitter to whatever violence
broke those songs I got a I got a check
and I dispersed it amongst five or six
minors on my team and we break this on
and so then some up but then some of
them you you just say okay well in the
contract I got to keep this thing up for
a week and then I and then I'm gonna
take it down before brandy oh yeah we
keep it up up me the contract is usually
a week or two ten days because that's
when the band kind of like dies out and
you pull it I just didn't pull the beats
one cuz I like but I've put up brand
deals and then after a week it goes down
we pushed apps to the top of App Store
you know we we pushed songs to the top
of value to his charts I put our song on
myself and it set on the top of iTunes
shots in the hip-hop section for two
weeks you know so hmm I mean so you've
obviously asserted yourself in this
medium and you've done so much with
YouTube and you know we've got all the
history there but I'd love to paint more
the derive the whole backstory and just
go back to that Oh give us the DeStorm
backstory
where'd you grow up I grew up in um I
was born in Virginia
stay there for like not even a year and
then my mom moved and I have seven
siblings we grew up I grew up in
Baltimore the projects of Baltimore City
you know Baltimore is a very unique town
you Baltimore is one of the only cities
in this country that they use to
actually test new drugs so like if you
think they like the government whoever
whoever it is like if there's a new drug
on the market they just put it pumping
in the black community and bought
it's Weiss a lot of crackheads like when
they say crackheads that's like
Baltimore that's what pretty much was a
minute I think of the wire the the
series
the wire is like a very polished version
of Baltimore and it's super gritty and
it's super great it's a great I mean
have you watched it or you're like why I
watched I watched some of it and I was
just like oh my god this is not really
my town my town is worse than this worse
than that oh yeah I can't imagine what
do you mean worse how could it be worse
than the then the wire what white people
enjoy on television it's closer
cuz you got a good actually I saw like
bodies in those row houses when coming
home from school I see dead bodies in
the row houses
I see like a seven year old girl gets
shot in the head in the bodega day I'm
calling bodegas of Ottawa in the corner
store you know you see some crazy how
over you when you see a seven-year-old
gets shot and I said that's white like
13 and this is just straight gunfire
yeah because it's some guy old another
guy money he didn't have it and he shot
at him and they hit the girl did you
know I know the girl no she probably
from the projects across the street but
I mean in Baltimore you fighting every
day I mean it wasn't a date I went by
what we wasn't in some type of fight you
know or me my brother's wasn't fighting
other kids and stuff though and you said
in your draw my life video on YouTube
that your mom and you you the kids you
guys left your dad and that was when are
your dad left Wow therefore I was living
in the projects my mom and dad was
happily met well not unhappily married
and he was abusive so my father was
abusive man and he would hit on my mom
so I would fight him and he would knock
me out so she didn't want me to grow up
and even kill him or him kill me so she
left and took the kids and he didn't
give her the house so that's when we
moved to the projects so she took the
kids we moved to the projects and then
it's like whoa crack crap I'm 13 just
becoming a teenager and I'm living in
the projects now I got to learn how to
not be a suburban ish middle-class kid
now I gotta learn how to be a ghetto kid
so from 12 I think I was 12 or so from
12 to you know 17 18 you know I'm
growing up in the projects hmm trying to
learn to adapt and so at that point was
your dad just completely out of the
picture yeah he was gonna he too he
bounced he went he was some crazy liver
liberalist who move who was
you know conspiracy theorists who just
dipped you know I don't even know if
he's still alive I heard a few years ago
he was dead somewhere so I don't know
hmm how did you adapt um to the projects
you you learn how to fight my mom put me
in like things like karate so I had my
purple belt and go in you know Taekwondo
and you learn how to just street fight a
lot we didn't have money so we moved
around a ladder with like five
elementary schools five middle schools
and we would just get evicted a lot you
know we was eating from behind the
supermarkets you know just get out and
to adapt we would um just we would just
fight I had my brothers my mom just
taught us to stick together you can't
come in the house unless you bring your
brothers with you so I was one of those
things where family was just tight we're
still tight today because of things that
she taught so you know you you learn how
to just become conniving I'd you know
boost cars and running you know just
things I wasn't so proud of but breaking
in people's houses and stuff you know to
survive you know it's just what we did
it's did you did you get caught yeah I
got caught I went you know I got locked
up a few times you know I got um went to
juvie first and then you know when you
first get locked up the first thing they
say is you got to go in and you gotta
knock some I upside the head are you
gonna become somebody's [ __ ] so I went
in and I just had to knock some kid
upside the head so they would know that
I wasn't playing games that worked oh
yeah it worked and so you were the
youngest boy in the family right younger
sisters but all older brothers oh yeah
four younger sisters three older
brothers one of my brother's was a like
you know he wasn't within the house as
much because he was you know sling and
he was a street pharmacist oh I get it
right I guess so I mean with three older
teenage brothers my in this and you know
the outcome of a black male in that
situation and typically you killed or
you get you go to prison or you go to
prison or you die of something like some
disease and somebody mean I don't have
any friends that grew up in that area
that made it out but my mom was she was
one of those types that kept us in
activities I think it was a blessing
that we didn't have a TV and radio so
she kept us just doing creative things
we make up songs and just rap about cars
going down the street and we would just
and then she sent me to the School of
the Arts on a scholarship because I was
a good artist so I went to like butter
City School of the Arts and I started
joining like murals on church walls and
in mosques and things like that like the
Last Supper and and Allah permission
with formation didn't just break in and
do it guys so did the juvie experience
was that like the awakening or and then
it was the turning point to positivity
oh did it did it go further in the
opposite direction after that no it went
further in the opposite direction after
that but I think the awakening was you
know um just just realizing how hard my
mother was working to try and do
something positive like she's busting
her ass to get us to do something and
just seeing everybody around me die how
bad did it get for you personally um he
got bad but I think the music you know I
was I was always running track with his
never no money in in in track and field
but the music when I song hit the radio
and my mother she approached sweets like
God you got you you know you boys
eyetality
you got nothing and you got a song
that's playing in all those nightclubs
it's all really yeah we had you know
they didn't have Baltimore club music
like wait for the big group all that
type of stuff so we had to like hits on
the radio me win like me and my brother
okay so you know my brother actually I
felt was more talent than me who's a
better rapper you know he just had more
skills and was that did that come from
like mixtapes being passed around or
from knowing somebody and haven't know
we do a TV studio
we know a DJ we would just go into his
studio and just do stuff and then we had
a song that just blew up you know and
then you know all the radio just picked
it up and then my mother was like if you
can make it here didn't just go to New
York and see if you can make it there
and I'm like 17 18 years old my you know
my son's on the way and I'm like I gotta
get out of here so I threw me a party
and I just went to New York yeah so so
how are you and when you had your son uh
I was I guess I was turning 18 when TV
on was born um 18 or 19 years old I
wasn't 20 yet hmm and you but you were
so before he was born
you went off to New York in order to so
yeah so I I am mom up on her challenge
go another day another chance day
another challenge I would I knew a guy
named doobie who worked at Bad Boy
Records and me and him would talk back
and for
and I remember being in Marilyn and I
would do I did like a hundred drop so
different DJs and I would email them to
him and they were using them in their
mixtapes so my name is blowing up he's
like this DeStorm guy he's kind of like
blowing up on the mixtape scene and then
he was gonna do B so I hurt my stuff he
was like man you gotta come in New York
I work a bad boy and in your mind
someone works at a label you gonna go be
like Oh like this is huge so I packed up
my little eclipse I mean I got a little
money to get that I was working at Red
Lobster down in Maryland and I packed my
clips and I just went to New York I
landed I was standing this crackheads
house on 135th 134 fine and platon
Powell and um you know when I got there
I'm I'm working at bad boy as an
engineer with him and he got fired
because him and um I think like Harv
Pierrot
I don't know who it was at the time they
got into an argument and then doobie was
like man you know if you came here with
me we out and I'm like what you mean we
out I came all the way from Baltimore I
can't just be out but my loyalty had you
know I had to roll with him so I didn't
have that gig anymore but I had my job
from Red Lobster transfer to New York
New York actually I worked there with
alpha cat from you to lobster yeah so
you met same exact times where I met out
okay so we work it we working at Red
Lobster Times Square whatever and I got
fired because I had these long braids in
my hair and I remember like even I'll
forget what I might want to cut your
head it's your only job I cut my hair
Samson losses they lost his power like
that and then next thing I got fired but
I sued the whole Red Lobster
organization not one and it I didn't
give you that take I took years but the
point is I want so I didn't get any
money at the time so I'm jobless and my
last check was like like you got seven
different types of shrimp shred a
lifetime shrimp
I know Fredo sauce and biscuit cutter
biscuits cheddar biscuits I
but at the time you're you have braids
but you have no job you have no bad-boy
connect had nothing I had a chin what
you had a check for like $400 and with
the four hundred and some odd dollars I
forgot what it was I guess you gotta
watch my jaw my life plug and I'm so
with the four hundred and some odd
dollars I I bought five items I called
my brother and I told him when I was
going to do it was
my master plan at the time I I think
back and I guess I'm crazy but I paid my
cell phone bill for two months I brought
two outfits I bought an amp and a
keyboard
I got Tennant windows for my car and um
tented windows for your car right so let
me tell you the plan so so the plan was
I knew see the crackhead right that at
whose house I was living in she had his
pimp and he was a big black dude right
and I knew I couldn't take him Oh at
least I didn't think I could take him so
I know if I didn't pay his rent he was
gonna kick me out of the house right so
I said I this they're gonna kick me out
of the house so I need to tape the
windows on my car so I could have
somewhere to live okay got it got it so
privacy right so I bought the amp in the
keyboard which is ironic because it's an
eclipse
I bought the app in the keyboard because
I knew that I needed a job I knew that I
had a couple little bit of pipes on me
and so I said in New York no one knows
my face like that I could go into the
subways and I could sing and make some
money at least so I could put gas in the
car and get food every night until I get
back on my feet so that was gonna be my
job so I was the amputee keyboard thing
right right so then I bought the two
outfits because I knew I had to continue
to do gigs throughout New York because I
wanted to get a big break so I was still
doing shows in Harlem Brooklyn Queens
and Manhattan doan shows because and you
got to look good at these shows cuz no
one's gonna take your demo anything if
you don't look good at the shows so I
had to get the outfits gotta look dope
in New York got it
so finally I paid my phone bill for two
months because the scariest person in
the world to me is my mother and then
she can't get in contact with me and I
don't have my phone on she's gonna whip
my ass plus I was lying to her telling I
was hanging out with Diddy and stuff and
she's like hi you're falling off her if
you hang with Diddy so I had to keep
living this life so I kept my phone on
and said good I would just keep my phone
on so that was what I did with the last
bit of the money so next thing you know
I'm living in my car and everything
start work out I told my brother would
happen he thought I was crazy and we
continued on to the on that road so your
brother was up there with you too
no he was he was back home telling me
bringing his home and take that $400 get
on that Greyhound
did it get worse before it got better
Paula got WAY worse I came home one day
in the car that I that I was living in
it got ups the Eclipse come on man it's
a dope car whoever has an eclipse man
shoutout to you
oh the clips got burned up so sorry what
you weren't in it I know I was coming
I was I was coming at home and they
burnt my cookies burnt down they said it
was solids okay so it was a solar
eclipse it was a solely the tinted
windows didn't help this is this story
is crazy
hey man it was a solar eclipse they
burnt my car down the app keyboard
everything was in the clips is that your
hope your whole life was in their whole
life I had the outfit on my back and my
phone in my pocket but I had to pay the
bill I was with Sprint you know they cut
you off once you go a penny over mm-hmm
anybody would spray yeah I know that I
think AT&T or Verizon they burn your
okay so what happened then who is they
by the way I don't know the cop said it
was some kids who did it or they said it
was an electrical fire but I didn't get
it because it was the middle of February
it's freezing snow was like frickin five
feet high how does it even does it even
a flame at that dead temperature
science science I don't know definitely
weird so I mean so then what you're
homeless I'm homeless eventually I found
myself living in the subway so I'm in a
subway system and I was one of those
homeless people in New York what were
you what were you thinking at that point
we you know I've always wondered when
somebody's in that situation are they
thinking oh I'm I'm gonna get out of
this it's only a matter of time are you
thinking like this just the beginning of
me being this person for you know
actually you'd be thinking like damn I'm
hungry um let me find out how am I eat
right that's all you really think are
you immediate you're just immediate
about these thinking about your day'll
your day-to-day you don't think about
your future you don't think about your
past you just think about your get that
moment like I'm cold
okay I'm hungry oh my god you got
McDonald's I smell so good so the day
the dust is going through your head you
know any because you can't think
straight he's gonna feed your brain so I
would sit up you know till 6:00 I would
ride the subways you know throughout the
day and just try to figure things out
and you know when you finally eat then
you start
like okay now what am I gonna do no
one's gonna talk to me cuz I'm probably
dirty so I'll go and make season I'll
wash up and I'm okay now what am I gonna
do so you just sign up Macy's well yeah
because they had great great sinks that
was clean hmm
so let go no 40 seconds to you go to me
was 42nd whatever Macy's is on and I was
just go up there and wash up in these
things really you know and I thought
that was just my life for about six
weeks which is a long time people like
oh you just home ec the money that's a
long-ass time to be on the street um so
you know I don't camp more than two
nights at a time yeah right that's all
right
best thing is no rat infested subway
systems you know I was an in February
somewhere it's cold New York right so
some of the so from there um I was I'm
trying to figure things out
you know I'm like what am I gonna do I
guess I got to go home so i vish I
decided I'm gonna go home and I was
walking to make the phone call to go
home true story I was going to go call
my brother and say yo I'm coming home
I'm not gonna make it and a card and
then this one said in my job my life it
fell into the snow and I'm looking down
at this car and I'm like what do I call
this card a business a business card so
I like they're calling them on a
business card or do I call my brother
and go home what do you mean just a
random number on a business cuz because
the thing is like when you don't all
these shows people give you a bunch of
business cards and things so I had a
bunch of business cards and one of the
business cards fell into the snow
I picked the business card up and I said
I'm gonna call that number I called the
number on a business card this girl she
answers the phone she's like oh my god
they stormed my boss he loves you that
deaf he loved you demo he has to meet
you and I'm just as proud as dude I'm
like well if you want to meet me meet me
now cuz I got meetings and then she's
she's like no you can't meet him now I
gotta be amazing to meet him in two
weeks and I'm like thinking in my head I
ain't got two weeks I ain't got two out
I have two minutes so I was like now you
know what never mind cuz I thought it
was both because it's all book to me by
at that point everybody's bought so I
was ready to hang up when she said no no
let me just put Jonathan on the phone
she puts Jonathan Feingold on the phone
and John is like oh my god they stole my
love you demo man you gotta meet me he
said but I'm going to go out to the
Hamptons and chill I'll meet you in a
week I said Jonathan man you man
whatever I'm out the hey no no no come
meet me right
now sorry I called his bluff I jumped
the turnstile went to the Lower East
Side and I met with Jonathan going to
his pad there's lace - got platinum
albums and stuff I mean could he tell
that you were just off the street at
that point he was going up he was going
by my demo I know but when you walked in
the room when I walked in the room I
don't know what the hell he was telling
but I told him my story like straight up
he was just running his mouth like I can
do this for you I could hear I was like
well look look man if he will do
whatever for me cut me a check I'm
living on the streets and he was shocked
he was floored
so he cut me a check right on the spot
so and what would you do with that deal
- um from from there I'm I went from a
hostel to a little apartment to a studio
to you know a bigger studio he started
getting me placements on shows on MTV
vh1 I did some backing music for like aa
I did a lot of stuff what what years are
we talking about this was this was - yes
2005 mm you know for 2005 okay and um I
started getting back into my track and
field into my fitness and everything you
know just in case the music didn't go
well so I just became you know a better
better athlete all the while my family
knew none of this was going on so what
did they think was happening they
thought I was just had to label working
the whole time so so what for me they
actually start coming up and then we
start here things in like wow oh you
really came up and I'm like yeah I sure
did
so it was just one of those situations I
mean I've been through poverty so it was
nothing you know like for me to like
live that lie and then they found out
later it was like I knew something was
up
I knew it you ain't no when you talked
about some of the jobs that you had I
don't know exactly what 30 jobs okay 30
jobs yeah
so you mentioned some interesting ones a
construction worker pizza boy security
guard stripper I was I was as job as a
stripper I got into stripping cuz me and
my boy Sean it's gonna be a had a had a
party at in college and I went to Morgan
State then I went to Bowie State which
is a d3 school but she had a party in
college and the stripper didn't show up
so my friend Shayna and Candace invited
me and Sean what's up Sean they invited
us out to actually dance for the
you know because we were fit so they
said once I'll come dance boys will give
you 200 bucks a lot of money and cause
me ramen noodles so I was like you know
yeah what come dance for you so we
crawled out on our hands and knees on
all fours out of your bathroom I mean it
was nine girls in the room I get up on
the bed I'm dancing in front of the
girls in this big girl she pulls down my
pants and they all start screaming I'm
like Oh first I was embarrassed but then
I wasn't anymore
so the next thing you know my Sean's in
the corner with four girls entertaining
them and I'm on the bed entertaining the
other five girls they paid us to pull up
I was like oh my god this is amazing
that's the stripper that's a strike
that's what in a moment you realize I am
a stripper
[Applause]
Yeah right she stripped when you were
stripped but the thing is like five then
then we started a company called Five
Guys productions it was me shine this
dude named dreads and two other guys and
we would just go with different colleges
from cop in the Morgan to Howard and we
just go to all these different colleges
and we just dance for college girls and
right then I found myself and then I was
a stripper
so I started like dancing at a nightclub
and so that was between that was between
Baltimore and New York that was the
college experience the college
experience that was fun
okay so then I'm I'm trying to connect
the dots or I'd love to be connected
between the music experience to YouTube
okay so I was doing music I I were when
I finally I went to Universal Records
and I worked on there like Jeff Finster
I went to Atlantic on the Damon Eden who
cut me my first check for three songs
for a single and and and from there I
started writing for a lot of artists I
met with like Whitney Houston which was
amazing rest in peace
so I was just meeting a lot of artists
no but you met Whitney Houston in person
in order to potentially write write
three songs
three songs and they enjoyed the songs
actually but she was going through some
things and stuff like that so that was
kind of crazy but I was I was actually
becoming a more noted writer like neo at
the time
young writer in New York but music
doesn't sell it's fast and it takes a
while to get the checks and the clear
and stuff so I
knew I was good at fitness so what I did
was I got involved with fitness and I
became a personal trainer I got my NASM
my AC AC e and my EAS M which is three
certification is doing fitness I became
a personal trainer and then eventually a
master training I got my Stremme stretch
Pilates and kickboxing certifications
also so I started to train a lot of
clients at crunch fitness then I went
over to new health & Racquet then I went
over new exports Club for a few years
also so I'm training that New York force
Club in Brooklyn and I had this old-ass
lady she was like DeStorm I don't
remember my workouts can you put them on
the internet for me so I started putting
workouts on MySpace and what do you
remember her name because I don't need
to thank you know all right
so I don't remember her name though but
I remember putting her workouts on
MySpace and she didn't were you like
talking to her specifically
no no but okay hello Gladys yeah I was
like look Gladys damn it let me put your
workouts on MySpace so you can stop
forgetting me Gladys man
so I'm putting Gladys's workouts on
MySpace but she was too old did she
didn't have a myspace account you know
cuz it was young guys me Tom you know so
I'm we're sitting on MySpace and all my
other clients way he would log in
because they had you know myspace
account he didn't have one so I was like
I kind of finds where else to put their
workout so I'm looking for and then I
found YouTube I go to youtube and this
is whole new world I put it on there and
when I put it on it was like getting all
these comments with the fitness videos
was getting comments for people I didn't
know I'm from Germany just hit my video
so I read the article and it was talking
about guys like you and Phil Franco and
stuff like that no like who would ease
what do you mean a youtuber what does
that even mean so I start studying you
guys and I'm like wow these guys have
like this is crazy
so that was back when before you could
just get a partnership by uploading a
video this was like when you had to have
those three stipulations a certain
amount of views so I said I'm fighting
get these describe when I get my first
Google check I'm gonna be the man so I'm
right I'm right trying to get my first
Google check so that I can start making
money on YouTube and that's how I
started getting knowing the whole
YouTube thing just fitness yeah I was
just doing fitness not no music at all
but then like would you even like if you
go back now the earliest videos I
there's a I think there's a lot that you
made that you are now private but
there's still
some fitness videos there but they kind
of have a hook to him oh yeah that it's
seen I don't know if you change the
titles later or if you even knew from
the get-go from your studies that you
give it that title like what was the
high jump winner oh yeah it was like the
highest jump ever or the best push-ups
ever I knew that I had to give it a time
I knew that early though all those video
get millions of views I have some of the
highest view fitness videos because I
knew if I titled them I knew years down
the road that people will watch them
because of the title and thumbnail I
just knew that off the jump because this
is back when you only could pick with
the three thumbnails you couldn't even
upload a thumbnail right so I was doing
that and then I said I said I got to
become a youtuber not just a guy on you
two I have to become a personality and
that's when I think it was like seven
eight nine was that that was the
defining moment for me because I that's
when I met you guys yeah and I it was
the it was seven eight eight and I said
I can write songs I've been doing this
all my life I said I'm gonna make a song
it was 11 o'clock at night I wrote the
song I'm at seven eight nine whatever
that song it just justice just to fill
people in seven eight nine July 8 2009
July of 2009 was a YouTube gathering of
YouTube creators one of the first one of
the first first we went to it was just
creator LED like some smaller YouTube
channel in New York pull this thing
together in New York
right so Lou up there and I wrote a
number that's when I wrote that song and
I said I'm gonna get all these big
youtubers I studied all y'all and I saw
them get all these big youtubes to be in
my in my song I said why would they say
no it's a gather and this is the way you
do it and if I write something and I
show them that this guy has all this
talent they'll they'll jump in and
that's when I did that um well we were
in it right yeah you were yes
again a student and then I just a
voracious appetite for figuring it out
and then a tenacious commitment to get
it I asked what I remember for the first
time I met you was voracious and
tenacious mentally and you were gonna
kill like no you knew it you know and I
even made the lyrics you know that
everybody want to sing it you know I
didn't know
but I do you could come subscribe to my
YouTube almost famous and then I would
just let him know that I'm almost family
cuz I knew one day I would would crack
you know site oh it all makes sense now
yes I had like a plan you know and then
it just saw just like formulated and
came together you and so the next few
years you experience some incredible
success on YouTube and then you've been
pretty public about this in 2012 there
was a change on the YouTube platform
that impacted your views you actually
wrote a piece in Forbes about that it's
like you're the another day another
challenge guy you did a whole year of
that which you know was really sent you
through the roof on YouTube but then in
your own words that I don't know if you
use the word collapse but you tell us
well I did like IIIi did like I fell -
which was doing that - challenges it was
a hundred channel I did a hundred
challenges um I just did them like every
Monday and Wednesday actually talked to
Joe Penna michiga Tommy and he was like
I'm doing Tuesdays and Thursdays they
still want to do Mondays and Wednesdays
and you just blow up just do every two
times a week he's like if you write a
good song and I said I write I just
write a good song and next thing you
know I'm you know making CNN and you
know everything from national
Geographics you name it and I'm starting
working with collaborators not clever
with everybody from you guys - Justine -
you name it every youtuber then I think
2012 came around late 2012 they started
changing the platform and this was back
when when if you had good content
especially as a musician you can compete
against the you know the Rihanna's
Eminem's and if you have good content
you'll make front page and just you just
do it it was fair YouTube changed the
platform on us and when they changed the
platform on us I'm not gonna be quiet
about it that so I said yeah you changed
the platform and when they did that I
think a lot of the grandfather channels
in there started to lose a lot of the
views and my channel was hit and I
noticed I started getting all these
comments from people saying oh really I
didn't get your video and then my
Twitter started started blowing up and I
was like how many of you got my videos
and everybody's like none of us so I
went to my facebook like none of us so I
I realized that so I went and I took a
trip to AXA YouTube because do - loved
loved me at the time and they still do
so I would take a trip to YouTube and I
wasn't supposed to talk about it as they
say but I don't care man I make my own
money I went down and I said is there a
problem with
my channel they said yes there is a
problem with the channel that we can't
fix on the back end they said only about
20 to 30% of your your subscribers are
getting your videos and we can't really
fix it I said well can you at least take
this over million subscribers I have and
push them to another channel so that I
can start because I'm tired of making
content and it fail it because as soon
as they change the platform I went from
getting a million views of video to
literally probably like 150 to 200,000
views of video so I'm at the top of my
YouTube game and I'm like wait a minute
so this is not you know it's not working
for me anymore
so that's why I did the they was like
well we can't fix it I said well you got
to figure something out because you know
I'm losing you know six seven you know
so much money you know and not even not
just my fans are not seeing it so I got
people complaining to me like oh my god
we're not getting your videos you
sellout you left us I'm like no I'm
posting but you're not seeing my video
what you want me to do so it became a
thing so that's when I did the article
and for a new and new media rockstars
just telling them about how YouTube was
broken and they need to fix it
cuz YouTube started focusing on doing so
many other things with VEVO and I get it
it's business but at the same time they
forgot about the little guys like and
people who spent their life growing
YouTube and putting their name behind
YouTube and I wasn't gonna be quiet
about it but then what's the conclusion
of the matter for you at this point was
it well now look at me on vine how do
you see YouTube did something change or
did you shift no it's just like when I
see something blowing up you know like I
watch the kids especially like my son
and him they're like cool kids so I like
if I see them on something heavy I said
wait this must be the next thing so it's
like that are you I'm fine I'm like
what's fine so I said okay these kids
are watching it every day so I'll say if
it's this audience is the attention span
is that short and now they watch them
right I gotta get on fine but what
happened on YouTube and how do you see
it now because there's well I see
YouTube now is just a place I see it for
my personal channel I see it as a place
to put longer form content I still look
and I know my fans are still there the
ones that can see it and I'm never gonna
probably get the views that I used to
get unless I grow a new audience on that
but now that I've grown I have almost I
have five almost five million followers
on vine already and I can take those
five million followers and just start
telling them to go check out my YouTube
videos and I can grow a new audience
that will see the videos and although
the million that I lost or whatever on
you
tube already a gun I could get a whole
totally new audience to start watching
my longer form content and I knew that
was the overall plan so I put I
dedicated a year and a half into vine
and and you know I grew 5 million
followers and I'm gonna take those 4.5
million followers you know I'm getting
300 400 thousand followers a month on on
vine and your YouTube channel is your is
the home for your singles that you
release so yeah so now I use it for like
I use my music channel just to release
singles and things and a lot I'm gonna
push through my vine and stuff like I
put out a victory dance and it's already
hitting 600,000 views that's good for me
on YouTube and how much our time and
energy are you investing as a musician
well you know music is my first thing so
I'm always gonna vest time but I'm not
putting out EPS
oh I'm not putting out albums anymore
I'm just trying to get that one single
because my job
I already already did a single that did
100,000 units I put out a you know a a
record and I sold 50,000 units but as
being a vine comedian a real barrier to
being a legitimate recording artist no I
don't think so because of the type of
comedy I do like I'm not doing like you
know I'm just being me and I just find
it funny
you know it's not like me acting as a
character so it doesn't take away from
me as a recording artist and Plus in the
beginning I always established that I
was a recording artist so like you know
I go on in I just do funny stuff and
there's other you know musicians on vine
that's just you know do funny stuff
you know I'm saying so I don't think it
hinders me I think that but to be six
but to be successful as either one of
those things don't it take everything
you've got I mean especially with the
way the music industry is you know
because I you know you know I've gained
so many relationships now you know I'm
saying like now like oh my god now he's
chilling with Justin Bieber now like oh
my god now Jake's calling they wanted
Jake want to go vine Nicky laughing at
the vines oh my god that's so funny you
know I'm saying so you got all the
biggest musicians in the world who I
think vine is is old owner we gotta
pause now cuz you just dropped a couple
of names and we got a we got it so
you're talking hanging out with Justin
Bieber was talking with Drake well yeah
because these are real experiences these
are well yeah I got a vine with Justin
you know we did it vine with Justin I
know at what point in
in his life was this there's been many
phases he has allowed to fake actually
he's one of the coolest dudes man we now
go to parties we just wanna party with
him last week you know so like he's a
cool dude this is you know like III
think in his his situation a lot of you
just don't understand like it's hard I
wouldn't want to live his life because
he can't even go out in the street you
know and it's just difficult because I
when I go to his house I see the lines
wrapped around the corners like can you
go to Chipotle
you know like it's just hard but to live
that life so you just become this
introvert and it's kind of a problem
hanging you know hanging around but he's
cleaned itself up a lot I've seen when
he went through the whole phases of like
messing with some some hard stuff and
now he's like you know he's good you
know and he's working on music again
he's he's doing well but when you talk
about Drake or Nicki or any of these
people I mean I guess your point is that
your vine status is your is your access
to everyone whatever whatever you want
whatever you want vayas dick with
YouTube it was more of an underground
movement but vine is more of an
overground moving the traditional really
latched on the vine that's why you see
them on worldstar and things like that
and actually in reality I get more views
from my vines on YouTube then my YouTube
channel ever got just by just by you
know people putting my compilation
compilations yeah my compilations do
better than my entire YouTube channel so
you know vine opened doors that I never
I never was able to touch you know the
people that I wanted to contact even
through my youtube you know the vine
just opened those doors you know we work
with everybody from kidding - you name
them we probably work with them all on
the vine because it touch traditional
meter media more than you know YouTube
did and now your son just passed a
million yeah my son had a million
followers on vine shoutout TV on who had
a million followers on vine so he's
playing he's killing it - so I mean tell
us about that because you know we've got
kids a little bit younger than him who
are asking about starting YouTube
channels etc and we and we it's so far
they haven't done anything but you know
what's your what's the status your
relationship with your with your son now
is he live with you how often you yeah
this is me
um we both live together just me and him
I'm a single father who's raising him
and his crazy-ass friends I'm gonna feel
like I'm a father to everybody but I
raised him you know and he's doing well
you know he he fell he sees us finding
and things like around that so makes him
kind of want to do it he got involved in
it early and he's a no now he has a
million followers on vine he's about to
get you know he just landed he just did
that national Jordan commercial you know
with Jordans first community one of
Jordans first shoot commercials that
came back my son was the main character
in that and he's getting a lot of work
you know Disney Nickelodeon now he's
about to get like a huge management
manager who's gonna like really just
start to push his career to the next
level
he's a little lazy TV I'll get off your
ass but you know so what's your I mean
what's your fatherly advice for him um I
just tell him to do what he loved
you know don't don't following anyone's
footsteps do what he wants to do like if
he wants to be a football player doctor
astronaut whatever he wants to do I want
him to do I don't I don't force him to
do anything and he just does it on his
own ecologist I just want him to stick
to something I just tell him don't be a
quitter that's that's my advice whatever
it is he do just don't quit and and then
he's doing well you know he gets his own
brand deals and um you know I can't you
know I I can't even control that little
bastard man well you I mean you tell him
not to follow anyone's footsteps but if
he follows in yours I think that uh
he'll be fine he'll be just fine
yeah so yeah we appreciate hearing your
story and I would ask you to sign the
table but unlike any other guest ever
you just sat down and signed it oh man
you know their egg ban people at home
like they tempt me they got water coffee
in a magic market man it's like you know
what you want me to do so I grab the
magic marker and I just had to hit a
vein it's fine it's done it's good okay
and all right and this is done I guess
thanks man
no doubt thanks for having me
[Music]
and there you have it our ear biscuit
with DeStorm power I learned a few
things I think the main thing that I'm
taking away from this is that if and a
business card ever drops in the snow
mm-hmm you should pick it up call it no
questions asked
what you should call the number on the
card you shouldn't call the card you
should call the number on the how would
I call the card when you mean like a dog
I said pick the card up you said call it
you mean the number on the card that's
right thank you for Claire I know that
you're sitting there and whatever you're
sitting in our honor
listening to us and you were totally
confused somebody here may be jogging
maybe you're jogging thank you for
clarifying that
I let DeStorm know what you think of his
story and his conversation with us
tweeted him it's DeStorm and use hashtag
ear biscuits as de storm nothing the
thing we're like lightning and thunder
happens now in that's in the TV movie
that we're working on for this four day
storms life I do think that when the the
business card drops into the snow that
there should be a beam of light on it
because we can really sensationalize
things right and then the snow starts to
melt no no the business card when it
falls it melts all the snow around it
and it can have a mouth and it can start
talking mmm that's a little weird that's
going too far
then you really could call the card a
little mixed media action happen in
there special effects claymation it's
gonna be a claymation business card it's
gonna be like a star call the number
written on me so look change you looked
forward to that in 2018 but we're gonna
start working on it immediately will be
instagramming from the from the set yep
and you know what that may be the final
thing that causes us to start a vine you
know the making day storm the movie
because I mean I gotta tell you I will
say that every time we talk to someone
who has a vine presence which I you know
I know we talked to alpha cat and then
we talked to they storm we talked to
anybody else who's really killing it on
vine I don't know not yet
we will do that more in the future but
and you'll feel the pressure to it you
always feel this pressure
there's only six seconds right I mean
you could do that we can carve that kind
of time out right what pressure do you
feel having listen to this here biscuit
with us I hope it is a pressure to feel
less pressure and just to lay back and
enjoy what we're pumping into your
earhole negative pressure yeah feel the
negative pressure that's what we should
make a shave the suction feel the
suction on your earholes
nope that's not t-shirt material nope
okay listen next week yeah we'll be here
[Music]
[Music]